hallo deutsch schwule doppelte laute
kgl
mtt
die haare die haare die frau hat lockige
haare sie hat locken die frau hat
lockige haare sie hat locken der mann
hat ganz kurze haare er
trägt eine kurzhaarfrisur
der mann hat ganz kurze haare er
das mädchen hat lange haare
sie trägt eine langhaarige
hast du kurze oder lange haare
der kam
der kampf ist aus recyceltem
plastik
ich käme mir die haare mit dem kampf ich
käme mir die haare mit dem kam
als friseur brauche ich einen kamm zum
arbeiten als friseur brauche ich einen
kampf zum arbeiten meine friseurin
camp mir immer zuerst die haare meine
friseurin
camp mir immer zuerst die haare
wie oft gehst du zum friseur
die batterie
die
batterie
die batterie hat einen pluspol und einen
minuspol die batterie hat einen pluspol
und einen minuspol
in einem auto gibt es auch eine wichtige
batterie die
autobatterie in einem auto gibt es auch
eine wichtige batterie die
autobatterie
wenn die batterie leer ist dann
muss man sie aufladen wenn die batterie
leer ist dann muss man sie aufladen
endlich ist die batterie wieder voll
geladen
juhu endlich
ist die batterie wieder voll geladen
wo für benutzt du eine batterie die
trommel die trommel ein schlagzeug
besteht aus vielen trommeln ein
schlagzeug besteht aus vielen trommeln
das ist übrigens auch eine trommel die
sogenannte
wäschetrommel
das ist übrigens auch eine trommel die
sogenannte
wäschetrommel die wäschetrommel in der
waschmaschine
dreht sich beim waschen die
wäschetrommel in der waschmaschine
dreht sich beim waschen der drummer in
der band trommelt richtig gut der
drummer in der band trommelt richtig gut
welches instrument findest du am besten
das billard
das
billiard in vielen bars und kneipen
gibt es auch ein
billardtisch in vielen bars und kneipen
gibt es auch einen billardtisch am
anfang von jedem billardspiel legt man
die
billardkugeln auf den
billardtisch am anfang von jedem
billardspiel legt man die
billardkugeln auf den
billardtisch
heute abend spielen wir ein bisschen
billard in der kneipe heute abend
spielen wir ein bisschen bildet in der
kneipe oh mann
hoffentlich kann ich die letzte
billardkugel versenken oh man
billardkugel versenken spielst du auch
gerne billard
der 2
der zoo im zoo
leben viele
verschiedene tiere aus der ganzen welt
im zoo leben viele verschiedene tiere
aus der ganzen welt
so ist die abkürzung für das wort
zoologischer garten
so ist die abkürzung für das wort so
logischer garten in berlin gibt es sogar
eine eigene bahn station mit dem namen
zoologischer garten
in berlin
gibt es sogar eine eigene bahn station
mit dem namen
zoologischer garten
ja genau wir treffen uns an der s bahn
station
zoologischer
garten
ja genau wir treffen uns an der s bahn
station
zoologischer garten
wann warst du das letzte mal im zoo
das diagramm
das
diagramm bei einem säulen diagramm sind
die ergebnisse
vertikal
angeordnet bei einem säulen diagramm
sind die ergebnisse
vertikal
angeordnet bei einem balken diagramme
sind die ergebnisse
horizontal
angeordnet bei einem balken diagramme
sind die ergebnisse
horizontal
angeordnet bei einem kreis diagramm sind
die ergebnisse in einem kreis angeordnet
bei einem kreis diagramm sind die
ergebnisse in einem kreis angeordnet in
einem diagramm gibt es eine x-achse und
eine y achse in einem diagramm gibt es
eine x-achse und eine y achse
wofür benutzt du ein diagramm
dribbeln
beim dribbeln springt der ball auf und
ab beim dribbeln springt der ball auf
und ab beim fußball kann man den bauch
kribbeln beim fußball kann man den ball
auch dribbeln ich dribbel den basketball
von einer hand zur anderen hand ich
dribbel den basketball von einer hand
zur anderen hand ich muss schnell den
fußball zum tor dribbeln ich muss
schnell den fußball zum tor dribbeln
spielst du gerne fussball die klamotten
die klamotten
klamotten ist ein umgangssprachlicher
begriff für kleidung
begriff für kleidung wow so viele
günstige klamotten alles ist reduziert
wow
so viele günstige klamotten alles ist
reduziert oh mann ich brauche ich
dringend neue klamotten oh mann ich
brauche ich dringend neue klamotten
die neuen klamotten sind super ich fühle
mich wie neu geboren
mich wie neu geboren wo gehst du am
liebsten deine klamotten kaufen die
waage die waage
die waage liegt das gewicht die waage
liegt das gewicht in der küche benutze
ich eine küchenwaage
in der küche benutze ich eine
küchenwaage
jetzt muss ich erst mal das meer
abwiegen ich brauche
600 gramm mehl
jetzt muss ich erst mal das mehl
abwiegen ich brauche
600 gramm mehl
was ist schwerer die linke seite oder
die rechte seite was ist schwerer die
linke seite oder die rechte seite hast
du auch eine waage zu hause die yoga
matte die yoga matte
ich mache yoga auf der yogamatte
ich mache yoga
auf der yogamatte
es gibt yoga matten in vielen
verschiedenen farben
weißt du wie diese farben heißen komm
wir gehen mal alle farben zusammen durch
blau
grün
rot gelb
weiß
schwarz lila
grau
orange braun
rosa türkis
was ist deine lieblingsfarbe
die flagge die flagge auf dem dach des
weißen hauses
ist eine amerikanische flagge auf dem
dach des weißen hauses
ist eine amerikanische flagge die flagge
der piraten ist die sogenannte
piratenflagge die flagge der piraten ist
die sogenannte
piratenflagge bei einem autorennen gibt
es eine sogenannte
zielflagge bei einem autorennen gibt es
eine sogenannte
zielflagge die
deutschlandflagge hat die farben
schwarz-rot-gold
die
deutschlandflagge hat die farben schwarz
rot gold
welche farben hat die flagge deines
landes
die kartoffel die kartoffel in
deutschland sind kartoffeln sehr beliebt
in deutschland sind kartoffeln sehr
beliebt
süßkartoffeln sind sogar noch
als normale kartoffeln
süßkartoffeln sind sogar noch gesünder
als normale
kartoffeln zu einem burger esse ich sehr
gerne
süßkartoffel pommes zu einem burger esse
ich sehr gerne
süßkartoffel pommes heute hole ich mir
aus dem supermarkt eine tüte
kartoffelchips
heute hole ich mir aus dem supermarkt
eine tüte
kartoffelchips ist du gerne kartoffeln
der bagger der bagger der baggerfahrer
baggert mit dem bagger der baggerfahrer
baggert mit dem bagger je so viel sand
ich brauche unbedingt ein bagger je so
viel sand ich brauche unbedingt ein
bagger kein problem
baggerfahrer max ist direkt zur stelle
kein problem
würdest du auch gerne mal in einem
bagger sitzen das weltall
das weltall die astronauten fliegen mit
einer rakete
ins weltall
die astronauten fliegen mit einer rakete
die internationale
raumstation iss
befindet sich im weltall die
internationale
raumstation iss
befindet sich im weltall
wegen der schwerelosigkeit
schwebt der astronaut im weltall
schwebt der astronaut im weltall im
weltall gibt es sehr viele satelliten
im weltall gibt es sehr viele satelliten
würdest du gerne mal ins weltall fliegen
abonniere den kanal der halle deutsch
schule und aktiviere das kleine
glöckchen
gib uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben und
klicke auf diese playlist für weitere
videos zum deutsch lernen